hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast how anthropogenic chemicals
are altering in microbial roles I'm
Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots nam be a
moderator for today's event labret skaam
is a meeting scientific social
networking site we are proud to very
newest interactive web seminar for more
information please visit us at lab let's
calm here's how the presentation works
we want to hear from you questions
comments and even answers can be
submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen will try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you via email you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly when it's now by clicking on
the support button at the top right or
the Q&A button in the lower left we
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Erica marine hartman she is
an environmental microbiologist
interested in the interaction between
our through the genic chemicals and
microbial communities she was the first
graduate of the interdisciplinary
biological design ph.d program at
Arizona State University where she
worked with environmental engineers to
develop molecular methods to detect
microbes in food soil and water samples
from there she was awarded a fulbright
to study microbes that parade the toxic
kosuna genic finish the foodies known as
dioxins in France at the Commission for
atomic energy in her kind of work at the
biology and the built environment Center
at the University of Oregon erica is
leading Studies on the effects of
antimicrobial chemicals on the microbes
found in indoor dust in addition to her
research erica serves on the American
Society for Microbiology microbiome
communication task force and as a
university of oregon expert and
microbiology let's turn it over to Erica
now great thank you um so to start out
with I have a cna disclosure and for
those who are interested its sheer
um and with that I'll just get started
so yeah I'm going to be talking about
how anthropogenic chemicals which are
chemicals that we humans make are
altering the world and the way that
microbes make their living and the first
thing that we need to all except here is
that we humans introduce chemicals in
the environment and we can do that
intentionally or unintentionally and
once these chemicals are in the
environment they interact with microbes
that we did or didn't know we're there
and the thing about microbes is that
there's so much more than just their 16s
genes i mean one thing that we tend to
do when we're looking at microbes in the
environment is focused just on looking
at who's there but i like to think of
microbes as bags of enzymes so there are
proteins and they're responding to the
physical and chemical stimuli in their
environment so bacteria microbes like
all cells are made up of four major
macromolecules lipids carbohydrates
nucleic acids and proteins and we care
about these macromolecules because
they're common among all cells but also
because they do everything that the cell
does so that can be energy storage or
structural support protection catalysis
transport defense regulation movement
heredity information transferred these
are all things that most cells do and
all of these actions are actually
performed by the macro molecules in the
cell when we look at the breakdown of
macromolecules in a Cell most cells
contain a majority of proteins in
addition to the nucleic acids that form
the genetic information that hereditary
information and then there are
carbohydrates and lipids and one thing
that I'm going to talk a lot about is
proteins and nucleic acids because those
are the most informative from macro
molecules and proteins especially I find
really interesting because they're what
what define the function
of the cell so bacteria perform many
many functions and all of these
functions are regulated by proteins so
for example digestion in your intestines
if you know anything about the human gut
microbiome you know that one of the
things that it does is it breaks down
food that are our human cells can't
metabolize but microbes also perform a
lot of ecosystem services like nitrogen
fixation they digest sludge in our
wastewater treatment plants they changed
the oxidation state of metals in the
soil causing metal reaching it can be
used for bioremediation so cleaning up
pollutants that we spilled in the
environment but proteins can also be
your lens factors or reflect pumps and
these are two things that we're going to
come back to but basically proteins do
everything that the cell is doing all of
those functions are linked to proteins
and so you need the genetic information
to code for these proteins but that
genetic information well it'll change a
little bit certainly more in bacteria
than it does in eukaryotes for example
in humans um what's going to change much
more dramatically over time is not the
genetic information itself but whether
or not a gene is expressed so if we look
at over the course of development of a
human for example even though the
genetic information doesn't change the
protein expression changes quite
dramatically and that's how we develop
from fetuses into humans so much like a
developing multicellular organism we can
think of a microbial community changing
over time and the big difference is that
the genetic information will change more
in microbial community than it would in
a periodic organism but in addition to
changes in genetic information and that
can be through sharing genes or just
changes in the relative abundance of
different species we can also see
changes in the phenotypes of different
species and even within single species
changes in phenotypes of individual
cells so what that means is that the
proteins that these cells are expressing
are going to change over
and as we'll see they're going to change
in response to chemicals especially
chemicals that we humans make and I'm
going to go through a really detailed
example bear with me just you can get in
a sort of mindset of how a bacteria
think and this is going to help us think
later about how bacteria might respond
in different situations so we're going
to start out looking at ecoli and
looking at the growth curve of e.coli so
this is the textbook growth curve when
you start a culture in pop culture you
typically have this phase in the
beginning called lag phase where there's
not a lot going on and then all of a
sudden this all start growing like
gangbusters in log or exponential phase
and then they hit some sort of limit
limiting situation where they go into
stationary phase so maybe they ran out
of food or there's not enough oxygen or
whatever happened and then slowly the
cells start to die off the death phase
and the traditional explanation for this
lag phase that phase the beginning where
there's not a lot going on is that the
cells are adapting from one phenotype to
another so they're expressing one set of
proteins that's not perfect for growing
in that culture and they move towards
expressing another set of proteins where
they are growing well in that culture
and so in this diagram that first state
the not super well adapted state is
shown in yellow and it moves over time
towards the purple well adapted state it
turns out that that's not entirely
correct and so there are a couple of
different explanations for what causes
lag phase if that is not the explanation
so you can see to hear it doesn't really
matter for the purposes of our example
which one is correct but the basic idea
is that you start out with a non adapted
population that yellow population still
and then either there's a very small
fraction of the population that is well
adapted and that's the fraction that's
going to take off so we can see that
purple curve going up on the left or a
certain portion of the non adopted cells
will diversify it'll actually change
phenotype some of them will
them all and the ones that do that adapt
really well again those are the purple
ones the ones that take off and so
basically the idea to take home message
is that we have multiple phenotypes
within the same population we have
purple growing cells and yellow non
growing cells so to look at how this
works we're going to go through one
example of shifting ecoli from glucose
to acetate and the basic experiments on
that behind this is to take um e coli
that's growing on lb so in plates
rich-media equal I are super happy pick
colonies and transfer them into minimal
media containing glucose ecoli legs
glucose everybody's growing very happy
transfer them again to glucose so
everybody's really really happy going on
on glucose everyone's well adapted and
then in the middle of the exponential
growth phase transfer them from glucose
to acetate which is a gluconeogenic
substrate and we'll see what that does
to the phenotypes of the cells in the
population what we're really interested
in here is looking at the shift between
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis i'm so
the idea is that when cells are growing
on glucose they're using the glycolytic
pathway which is this one here and when
they're growing on an acetate they're
using the gluconeogenic pathway which is
basically the same pathway but running
reverse an either way both of these
pathways take carbon from outside the
cell glucose or acetate and funnel it
into the TCA cycle so the cell can make
all of the things that it needs for
carbon and generate energy so it can do
things and if we look now at our
population of cells that were grown on
glucose and then shifted to acetate we
can see that there are two curves here
so this is looking at fluorescence of
the cells themselves and in the
membranes some of them were some of them
are actively dividing which is going to
change the way they fluoresce you get
these two curves one the yellow curve
doesn't change a whole lot this is the
fraction of cells that are not growing
so that's that's our phenotype
one and feedoe night phenotype number
two is the purple cells and those the
ones that are actively growing and if
you look at the graph on the bottom you
can see that the yellow cells are not
really changing over time where's the
purple cells are growing up which if you
look at them together is what gives us
our textbook lag phase growth curve so
again textbook log plays these are all
the same cells but we have two
phenotypes one that's growing one that
isn't and we know that this is in
response to a chemical stimulus acetate
because if we increase the acetate
concentration we directly influence the
phenotype we can change the growth rate
as we see in diagram a here and any
diagram feed we see that we can also
change the fraction of cells that are
actively growing so the proportion of
the population that goes into phenotype
the growing phenotype and this makes
sense so basically what happens is that
if we take away glucose we're favoring
growth on acetate but only some cells do
this right so we have these two
populations even though all of these all
of these equal I have the same genetic
potential only some of them are going
into this gluconeogenesis can
immediately use acetate as soon as that
glucose is gone and this may be due to
stochastic differences in
gluconeogenesis pression so basically
what that means is that some of these
cells just by chance because this is a
dynamic system had a little bit more of
the proteins that they needed to use
acetate right when that acetate was
available also the gluconeogenic pathway
and E coli is regulated by post
translational protein modifications so
again maybe just by chance some cells
had a little bit more a little bit less
of these post translational
modifications so as soon as that
acetates available as soon as the
glucose is gone these are the ones that
take off everybody else they don't make
it but they don't actually die and what
happens to them is really interesting so
the non growing cells
are not actually dead they are dormant
her sisters and we can see this if we
take the cells after they've now been
grown on acetate and they're not
actually growing we transfer them back
to rich media everybody's happy on rich
media and we see that a hundred percent
of the cells recover so what we're
looking at is viability over time and
what's interesting is if before we put
them on rich media we treat them with an
antibiotic we treat them with kanamycin
which only affects actively growing
cells you still recover a hundred
percent of your population more or less
however if you treat them with a flexus
in which is an antibiotic that attacks
all cells whether they're growing or not
you see a much reduced recovery so this
is log scale we're seeing from about a
hundred percent down to about twenty
percent of viability so that's really
interesting that just by changing from
acetate or from glucose to acetate we've
created antibiotic resistant bacteria so
I'm going to give you my conclusions
about what we just went through you feel
free to draw your own but my conclusions
are that even in a genetically
homogeneous population microbes can be
phenotypically diverse so even the same
set of genetic potential it seems that
our genes we can have different
phenotypes and even though we have
different phenotypes we can have
different levels of metabolic activity
but the same viability so even if a cell
isn't doing anything right now that
doesn't mean that it can't be doing
something in the future and also within
the same population individual cells can
have different antibiotic sensitivity so
the cells that were actively growing
we're sensitive to kanamycin and the
ones that weren't we're not sensitive
and these differences arise due to
external chemical signals so in this
case we were talking about glucose and
acetate but we're going to talk more
about anthropogenic chemicals so
chemicals that we humans make so one set
of chemicals that I'm really interested
in is antibiotics and we're going to
start by talking about
products and the human microbiome so
humans introduce all kinds of chemicals
into our bodies on things like glucose
and acetate might come from our food or
metabolites of the things that were
digesting so you eat a hamburger or
whatever it is you're eating that's
going to be broken down into smaller
macromolecules that your that the
bacteria in your gut are going to see
and start digesting but we also ingest
bioactive chemicals that we call drugs
some of which are targeted specifically
at microbes and these are what we call
antibiotics and we ingest drugs
basically it's just sending different
chemical signals down to the microbes in
our gut and the human microbiome
especially gut microbiome performs lots
of different services for us as posts so
the microbes in our gut for example
digest our food and keep our immune
systems working they're going to take
those chemicals the chemicals from the
food that we're eating and some of the
proteins for example that we can't
digest they will digest they're going to
make signals that are passed to the host
immune system basically keep everybody
happy and healthy um but we also expose
them to antibiotics and these
antibiotics I'm going to talk about
antibiotics as if they're one lump thing
but in fact of course there are many
different classes of antibiotics and
different antibiotics have different
mechanisms of action and they're going
to affect more gram positive versus gram
negative bacteria they're going to have
wider or narrower spectrum what I'm
going to talk about them as if they all
have one mechanism of action or not one
mechanism of action but one effect and
that effect is primarily changing the
microbial community composition so the
idea is that we take antibiotics and
before antibiotic treatment there's one
set of microbes in that community and
some of them just by chance just like
the microbes that could or could not
deal with acetate can cannot deal with
the antibiotics that we expose them to
and so after antibiotic treatment you're
going to see a change in the population
structure change in the membership
that microbial community and in addition
to that we're actually inducing
antibiotic resistance so um the idea is
that the microbes that can deal with
these antibiotics the ones that have the
antibiotic resistance genes and are
already expressing antibiotic resistance
proteins are more likely to survive so
those are the ones that we're going to
find afterwards but then some of those
genes are transferable so maybe even
some of the some of the bacteria that
didn't have that capability in the
beginning can acquire it in the face of
this chemical stress and they do this by
sharing antibiotic resistance genes so
antibiotic resistance genes are
typically on mobile genetic elements and
they can be shared through events like
conjugation or transduction so
conjugation is when two bacteria gets
together and they share a plasmid for
example and transduction is the same
idea of mediated genetic transfer
through bacteriophage and all of these
events increase when we when bacteria
are exposed to antibiotics so we can
look at the spread of antibiotic
resistance genes not just within a
single microbial community but actually
throughout the world so this study is
looking at the spread of the antibiotic
resistant the set of all of the known
antibiotic resistance genes in the
microbiomes of people in various
countries so we've got china malawi the
u.s. and Venezuela represented here and
you can see that in different places
throughout the world you actually have
different antibiotic resistance traits
and this may or may not have to do with
the chemicals that these microbes are
exposed to so different countries we
have different practices involving
antibiotic consumption and that leads to
differences in the patterns of
antibiotic resistance genes that we
observe
these kinds of data we can actually
track those resistance genes back to the
original microbes that contain them and
that's really interesting because the
same resistance gene does not
necessarily do the exact same thing in
all microbes so I just want to take a
minute and go discuss a specific case of
what what may or may not be antibiotic
resistance remembering that these are
just proteins and proteins are expressed
in response to specific chemicals so
antibiotic resistance an antibiotic
resistance gene is one that confers
antibiotic resistance in a specific
situation but that same gene in a
different situation may do something
completely different and this is the
case for the 2 prime n
acetyltransferases which Isetta lights
peptidoglycan so we can see pepto like
one here and what this protein does is
it just adds a little to settle group
onto it this is not antibiotic
resistance and its natural host
providencia sorority is not a human
pathogen so it doesn't encounter for
example a lot of the antibiotics that we
humans make however this gene can be
transferred to other pathogenic bacteria
and what happens then is they see the
antibiotic gentamicin if we take
gentamicin and the same protein
recognizes gentamicin the same way it
would recognize peptidoglycan and adds
in a subtle group so now it becomes
antibiotic resistance so my conclusion
is about a human microbiome is that of
course there are many different bacteria
but they're all reacting in different
ways to the chemicals to which we expose
them so they're going to react
differently to the chemicals in our diet
but especially to the antibiotics that
we are using to treat different
infections and these bacteria can share
antibiotic resistance so not necessarily
the way we might think not all of these
traits do exactly the same thing in all
hosts or in all in all bacterial hosts
um but there's certainly a certain
amount of sharing of genetic information
that goes on I'm
is in a direct response to the chemicals
that we are exposing these bacteria to
so once we've taken our antibiotics they
don't actually stay in us they can pass
into the environment where they affect
environmental microbes so this happens
let's say you take an antibiotic drug a
certain amount of that is going to get
metabolized in your system but the rest
of it is actually going to pass through
and go into the wastewater treatment
plant similarly we use a lot of
antibiotics in agriculture and
especially in raising a livestock and so
again a lot of those antibiotics some of
them are going into the actual livestock
but some of them are passing through and
directly through the manure get into the
environment and so what happens to these
drugs these chemicals in the environment
and now they're there they're
influencing lots of different microbes
that we didn't really intend for them to
influence so a quick note because I'm
going to switch from talking about
antibiotics you can't send microbials
and you've probably heard both of these
words before just by convention
antibiotics tend to refer to medicines
for humans or animals so these are going
to be you know the drugs that you take a
certain number of pills for a certain
number of days and they're really high
we tend to prescribe them in high dose
high-intensity for short periods of time
antimicrobials our agents that are used
to disinfect surfaces and eliminate
bacteria so these are going to be things
like your antibacterial soaps and from
the bacteria's for perspective these are
both chemicals that are trying to kill
them so they don't really see a whole
lot of difference but one of the big
differences between antibiotics and Anna
microbials is especially the way they
behave in the environment because
antimicrobial leave long-acting residues
especially on surfaces to be disinfected
that's what we design them for that you
apply something and you leave it there
and it retains its disinfecting power as
opposed to a drug where you take a
certain dose and then when it's when
it's over it's gone and so these animals
and have a prolonged action these are
referred to as residue producing and I
microbials and some really common
examples are triclosan and triclocarban
we're going to talk more about triclosan
but so just to say that antibiotics and
antimicrobial czar just classes of
bioactive chemicals that kill bacteria
so triclosan is used in toothpaste and
disinfectant solutions or cleaning
solutions and home watch these your
antibacterial hand soaps in most
households at least in the US and from
those households so if you're using a
toothpaste or hand wash you wash your
hands you brush your teeth everything is
washed down the drain from there goes
into a wastewater treatment plant and in
wastewater treatment plant things are
separated into the liquid and the solid
components so the liquid effluent goes
out into the surface water and the
solids can be applied to soil from the
soil and the surface water whatever
chemicals go along with those with those
effluence go into the groundwater where
they can then make it back into the
waterworks and back into our drinking
water and so triclosan is present in
consumer products in the milligram
program level and when we look elsewhere
in the environment we find them at much
lower concentrations which on the one
hand is reassuring but on the other hand
is a little disquieting because
basically what happens is you have these
very long-lived bioactive chemicals that
it high doses are lethal but at low
doses when they stick around for a long
time we might just be giving the
bacteria extra time to adapt to be able
to deal with these so that's kind of a
tricky thing to deal with is that now
you have these long-lived chemicals that
yes they're dilute but maybe because
they're dilute they lose a little bit of
their action and the bacteria get a
little bit better dealing them and one
of the ways they get better at dealing
with them is by developing multidrug
resistance so multi-drug resistance
comes in a few different flavors one is
the accumulation of multiple resistance
genes each specific to different drugs
so if you remember our classes of
antibiotics i talked about antibiotics
and antibiotic resistance as if there's
just one thing
but there's a whole host of classes of
antibiotics and there's a whole host of
classes of antibiotic resistance genes
so you can accumulate multiple
resistance genes that are specific to
multiple antibiotics or you can
basically just beef up your overall
defenses so this can be outer membrane
impermeability by increasing the
concentration of branched chain fatty
acids this basically just makes the
membrane a little bit trickier for
anything to get through so antibiotics
outside we don't really care and about
extending a cell that's when we get
worried as long as the antibiotics can't
get in the cell we're okay and these are
nonspecific so this is going to be
against lots of different classes of
antibiotics another thing that we can do
is have nonspecific be flex pumps and
remember we talked about these earlier
these are proteins that will just
indiscriminately pump antibiotics out of
the cells so an example of this or the
next genes and these here your
antibiotics get in and then we
immediately pump them out and as long as
we keep pumping about everything's okay
and then another option is to go into a
per sister state so this is for example
what we saw in response to switch from
glucose to acetate that some of those
cells instead of growing on acetate they
just go to sleep and when they're asleep
they're totally immune to any
antibiotics that effect growing cells
because they're not actively growing so
the thing about triclosan is that um it
can actually induce resistance not to
itself but to other antibiotics so what
we're looking at here is different pure
culture bacteria that have been
pre-incubated with triclosan and then
exposed to either chloramphenicol or
touch a cycling and what you can see is
that the minimum inhibitory
concentrations is what we're looking on
the y-axis here goes up sometimes by a
factor of five so you need five times
more antibiotic to kill these bugs now
than you did before they were exposed to
trick this am and this happens at
environmentally relevant concentrations
so these bacteria
we're exposed to concentrations that you
can see on the left these two left
columns showing the the different
strains of bacteria that were pretreated
with typos on and then you can see the
concentrations like I showed in the in
the cycle of triclosan in the
environment showing what concentrations
we would find in bio solids sediment
soil wastewater treatment effluence
groundwater and surface water and the
effect that we're seeing in these pure
cultures is not totally unreasonable
given the concentrations that we see in
the environment and we can see not just
in pure cultures that we're playing with
in the lab but in complex environmental
microbial communities such as here we're
looking at a community from a wastewater
treatment plant and we're looking at mex
be that's that multi drug efflux pump
and if we don't do anything to the
system we can see that the antibiotic
resistance doesn't change over time but
if we add triclosan to the system we
perturb the system in just over two
weeks we see over an order of magnitude
increase in antibiotic resistance so in
response to these chemicals we're
changing potentially the composition of
the microbial community but also the
phenotype what are these guys doing and
they are developing antibiotic
resistance so my conclusions about
environmental microbes are that the
drugs and chemicals that we that we
create for our use are our medicines and
our personal care products are found
outside of their intended environments
so not just in your toothpaste not just
in your medicine cabinet but also going
down the drain then we find them in
lakes and rivers and in the soil and in
all kinds of places and the bacteria in
the environment much like the bacteria
in a human microbiome are going to react
by developing antibiotic resistance so
they see these chemicals and they have a
way to protect themselves and they react
just as if you know just as if this were
a regular attack and because we give
them a long exposure here
with low chemical concentrations they
actually have a lot of time to develop
antibiotic resistance so we've talked
about antibiotics and what happens then
when we take them as as drugs and these
in this personal care products we've
seen that they make their way into the
outdoor environment by going through
wastewater treatment plants but a funny
thing is that they actually wind up
indoors and can affect indoor
microbiology so indoor microbiology um
is studying the bacteria and the fungi
that actually lived inside the built
environment and the first thing that we
have to accept here is that the built
environment is far from sterile so we as
hosts for example or bringing bacteria
in fungi bringing them into the
environment with us all the time so
we've got bacteria on our skin fundo in
our skin in our gut and we're shedding
these microbes everywhere you everywhere
you go you shed your microbes and we try
to curb the spread of these microbes at
least the ones that we don't want spread
around by practicing good hygiene
washing our hands for example but in
addition to that we also use chemical
controls such as antimicrobials to limit
again the spread of what we think are
bad microbes pathogens and these
chemicals we use are not just in things
like antibacterial hand soaps or hand
sanitizers but they're also embedded in
all kinds of products like these pencils
here these worlds best pencils are
protected by microban and microban is
the trade name of triclosan so the paint
that surround use pencils is embedded
with triclosan and we also find
antimicrobials in building materials so
things like paints and floorings
basically lots of things all throughout
the built environment contain
antimicrobial chemicals and lo and
behold triclosan is then found in indoor
dust so a couple of surveys have looked
at various places throughout the world
for tribal San in household dust and you
can see that there's almost 100
detection that means every sample we
take every just sample we take we find
triclosan in there and we find it at
concentrations that are on the low end
of what we find in wastewater treatment
plants so this is kind of shopping
because wastewater treatment plants are
one of the first places that we
identified triclosan as a contaminant of
concern and it's not just in your
wastewater treatment plant and it's not
just in the soil outside it's actually
in the dust in your home so one thing
about the indoor microbiome is that it's
shaped by architectural design so the
outdoor microbiome outdoor microbiology
is all of the bacteria that lived there
and have lived there for billions of
years the microbes that colonize us are
human microbiomes are the ones that are
uniquely adapted to to grow with us to
either be commensals or pathogens but
the indoor microbiome is a funny
combination of both of these things and
we can change we can alter the
composition of the indoor microbiome
through changes in architectural design
and building operation so one of the
things that we're looking at here for
example is where the air supply comes
from so if we have mechanically supplied
air so that's going to be your HVAC
system your air conditioning you have a
different microbial community than if
you have air coming in from the outdoors
from windows unfiltered air just an open
window blooming in so there's just one
interesting way that we can affect the
indoor microbial community so if we know
that architecture affects microbes and
we know that chemicals affect microbes
what happens when we put all of these
things together we now have the
chemicals that the same chemicals that
we are ingesting as drugs or using his
personal care products the same
chemicals that are causing antibiotic
resistance in the outdoor environment
and now we have the same microbes but
they're all mixed together so what's
happening here well it turns out that
just by being inside the built
environment poses a risk of
antibiotic-resistant infection so we
know this we've seen that there are more
cultivable isolates of Staphylococcus or
is inside and outside at home so if we
remember that the blue guys are regular
staph aureus and the guys with capes are
the antibiotic resistant staph aureus
and we take air samples from inside and
just outside of a home we find more
antibiotic resistant staph aureus inside
than outside and these are real data
I've just animated them to be more
friendly we also know from anecdotal
evidence that antibiotic resistant
infections yes of course they can be
transmitted from person to person but we
also know they can be transmitted to
domestic animals that can then turns
with them back to other hosts but even
in the absence of another host there's
something about the built environment
that can retain this
antibiotic-resistant infection and then
transmit it back to the inhabitants so
this suggests that there are there are
microbes in the built environment that
just like the microbes in your gut and
just like the microbes in the outdoor
environment are reacting potentially to
the chemicals that we're exposing them
to the same antimicrobial products that
we find in drugs the same ones that we
find outside we find them in dust we
find the bugs and dust maybe there's
something going on in there so this is
something that not a lot of people have
looked into yet and it's something that
my group is working on right now so you
can see some lovely pictures of us hard
at work harvesting microbes and looking
for chemicals and we're looking at to
see if there are correlations the same
way we see them outside between the
indoor microbiome and the antimicrobial
chemicals to see if there are changes in
community composition and changes in
antibiotic resistance and I don't have
any data to show you right now I
apologize but I can give you just my
preliminary conclusions from a pilot
study that we're running and we find
both human associated and environmental
microbes this is a picture of the
building that we're looking at here you
can see that it is ventilated through
windows that open so we would expect to
find a lot of environmental microbes but
also human associated the ones that are
being brought in by two people who use
this building for work and as a
classroom we also find low to medium
triclosan cost
tration so this is consistent with the
idea that because we're bringing in a
lot of dirt we're bringing in a lot of
air things are flowing through it's a
fairly dilute system that's leaky
architecture the natural ventilation the
windows that open there's also what we
call high infiltration even when the
windows are closed there are lots of big
gaps and so outdoor air and outdoor
microbes are still getting in despite
being a dilute system we still see
correlations between the antimicrobial
chemicals and the microbial community
structure and certain chemicals and
certain antibiotic resistance genes so
just like in the human body and just
like in the outdoor environment in the
indoor environment microbes are reacting
to the chemicals that we humans produce
so drugs and chemical products that we
intended just for our toothpaste or just
for our you know antibiotic drugs are
found not just in the outdoor
environment but also need indoor
environment and bacteria in the indoor
environment much like bacteria in the
human microbiome and in the outdoor
environment likely undergo changes in
community structure and function they
likely adapt in a direct response to the
chemicals that we as humans are putting
their so to summarize all of this just
remember that anthropogenic chemicals
the chemicals that we humans make exist
beyond their intended lifespan and
outside of their intended million
they're not just where we intend them to
go but they go out into the environment
they wind up in our homes in our offices
and these anthropogenic chemicals are
changing the chemical environment so in
addition to the glucose and acetate and
all of those things that bacteria used
to seeing there now also seeing
gentamicin and they're also seeing
triclosan and microbes react to
anthropogenic chemicals changing the
structure and function of microbial
communities so because they see these
chemicals some bacteria are going to
survive some are going to die so i'm
going to a purchase crew sister state
and some develop and I've got it
resistance so with that I'd like to
thank my research team who helped me
think about these things a lot the
collaborators
arizona state university and harvard
school of public health and i will take
any questions ok erica thank you for
that presentation i just want to remind
our audience to submit your questions
via the green Q&A button at the lower
left and we'll try to get to all of you
but if not we'll be sure to follow up
via email and our first question comes
from Russell at pester of X design Corp
great presentation Erica thank you very
much my question relates to soaps are
there any commercially available soaps
that are used for cleaning yet are not
antibacterial i yes absolutely so most
soaps that are not labeled as being
antibacterial don't contain
antibacterial chemicals and you can
actually see on a lot of the ingredients
lists if you look on the back of the
soap you'll see triclosan listed or
you'll see if it's bar soap triclocarban
and actually a lot of these
antimicrobials are being phased out of
consumer products but so yeah look at
the ingredients list of soaps and a
toothpaste especially those are those
are the two big things that we find
strike this in in and there are plenty
that don't have triclosan great
it's good to know I'm gonna have to
start meeting my labels and working
around at my dust making sure that it's
not looking too dangerous right don't
see any more questions coming in I want
to give our audience a little bit of
time to just manage the questions and
who cannot see oh here we are the 3d web
question from Diane hard raid the
college of southern nevada are there
historically equivalent events where
chemicals either anthropogenic or
otherwise have had a significant effect
on the environment so that's a really
interesting question um I would say yes
and a few examples I can kind of think
of off the top of my head would be
things like at the beginning of the sort
of Industrial Revolution when we're
making a lot of making a lot of progress
in one sense and maybe not so much me in
another we created a lot of interesting
chemistry for things like decreasing
agents we start using rockets we created
rocket fuel and a lot of these chemicals
when when we were first producing we
thought we were calling them xenobiotic
which means foreign to life so not
antibiotic killing life but xenobiotic
foreign to life and we thought for a
long time that these chemicals because
they were things that humans had created
they would just sit there forever but it
turns out that given enough time
bacteria actually evolved the ability to
use these chemicals as a source of
carbon and energy so we we changed the
function
certainly microbial communities in
places where these chemicals were
introduced to the environment so these
are going to be in the US your Superfund
sites things like that those are a
little more localized because it's you
know one chemical spill in one area
where as antibiotics and antimicrobials
are things that are being used worldwide
um a natural example I imagine imagine
there have been this would be things
like maybe if you have a volcano
eruption you or a forest fire you're
releasing lots of combustion byproducts
those are gonna be things like dioxins
and microbial community in the soil then
have to adapt to be able to use these
dioxins to be able to deal with things
like that um you know way back in
history when when microbes first started
releasing oxygen into the atmosphere
they then had to start dealing with the
presence of oxygen so I would say yes
there's a long rich history of chemicals
influencing the structure and function
of microbial communities on on various
scales whether that's the local scale at
your Superfund site or on a global scale
with oxygen in the atmosphere or
somewhere in between with antibiotics
and other microbials absolutely great we
have our next question from Brent aims
of pi open outcomes have you considered
comparing cohorts of people with
hypersensitivity to chemicals for
differences in their micro biomes
ah that's an interesting question I had
not thought of it but it does seem like
an interesting idea and something worth
looking into to see if that sensitivity
is derived maybe from something specific
to their microbiome if if their microbes
are creating a certain metabolite or if
they have a microbe that's specifically
sensitive to it that would be
interesting absolutely right our next
question Sarah was arrow from the
cassette what are your recommendations
to prevent or decrease the micro
resistance in a home environment so this
is something that is getting a lot of
attention right now as people are
becoming increasingly concerned about
antibiotic resistance so my personal
recommendations I'm not sure so I think
what is being recommended officially by
the majority of the scientific community
is things like we don't need all of
these antimicrobials use antimicrobials
when you need them not just all the time
so for example if you are immune
compromised yes maybe you should use an
antimicrobial soap but if you're not you
probably don't need it um things like
only take antibiotic drugs when you have
a bacterial infection especially eat
only if it's a serious infection if it's
something that you can clear on your own
maybe you should not take the
antibiotics but that's you know
something that needs to be discussed
with a doctor and I think the the
medical field is revising its opinion on
how antibiotics are prescribed and used
so my personal recommendations would be
you probably unless you have a specific
reason don't need antimicrobial products
so keep an eye out for for those and
keep them
your home and I'm yeah only take
antibiotics when you absolutely need to
great so many great questions coming in
I think we have time for one more from
Sofia at University of Barcelona what is
the mean time it takes triclosan to
degrade in the environment and is there
any way to accelerate this process you
know I have an answer to that sorry I
think um so try possums fate in the
environment has mostly been studied in
aquatic environments so it's half-life
in surface water or in a wastewater
treatment plant words in in an aqueous
environment can be quite rapid because
it can be it can be degraded by sunlight
but when it's sorbed to soil particles
or when it's sorbed to bio solids it's
pretty well protected so in that case
it's going to last a lot longer I'm not
sure on average what it is but it would
vary between you know on the order of
minutes to on the order of years
depending on that exact you know how
much how much sunlight there is and what
else is going on in that environment
okay this actually is our last question
from friend Eames again have you
examined the influence of surfactants on
development of antibiotic resistance or
other changes in microbial community
characteristics
so that's really interesting um one of
the things that we don't typically do is
look at at chemicals in combination and
hopefully it's something that we will
start doing more I think a lot of the
technology is getting there to be able
to look at microbial community responses
in in response to multiple chemicals at
the same time so surfactants are
interesting because a lot of things that
are not typically bioavailable things
that are sorbed to soil for example will
be released with biosurfactants and so
they become vital available at least
that was the thinking for a lot of for
example oil spills to clean up oil
spills to make the oil more available
for bacteria they added surfactants um I
think in a lot of cases what actually
happens is the bacteria just degrade the
surfactants because they're easier for
them to get so I'm not really sure what
what the responses for specifically
antimicrobials and antibiotics it would
be interesting to look at and I do hope
to see more studies in the future that
that look at not just one class of
chemicals but combinations of chemicals
on the entire microbial community okay
great questions with the questions done
I would like to once again thank dr.
Hartman for her excellent presentation
and dr. Hartman do you have any final
comments force no thanks very much for
your attention and hopefully I answered
some of those questions all right and
thanks again great if we were not able
to speak with you directly today we'll
be sure to follow up with you if you
have more questions you want to thank
our audience for taking part as well as
thank today's presenters centers for
joining us here at lab group Stockholm
the leading scientific social networking
site more information please visit lab
routes comm today's website will be
available for on-demand viewing through
februari 2016 you'll receive an email
lab reeks alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward that email to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event next time thank you thank you
bye